What can you tell me about some of your goals over the next few years?
My primary goal is to gain more work experience,...
...so, a position like this would help me meet that goal.
I'd also like to learn more about the different aspects of banking.
I think those goals are very smart.
I also want to ask you what salary range you'd be most comfortable with?
I would be hoping to start somewhere between 35,000 and 38,000 dollars a year,...
...which is based on my experience and education.
Thank you.
Those are all the questions I have for you today.
Do you have any questions for me?
Can you tell me about the working hours?
We'd like whoever fills the position to work nine to five each weekday.
There may be some occasional overtime.
Alright.
Thank you.
And when do you expect to be making your decision?
We'll give you a call within a week and let you know.
Do you have any other questions?
Not at the moment, thank you.
Well, if you think of any more, you're always welcome to call me.
Thank you so much.
It was great to meet you.
Thanks for coming in today.
Thank you.
It was a pleasure meeting you as well.